benvenuti soli dottore su stiamo rita e
berlino urbino ha sostituito vitale non
ero dietro ma ha deciso di prendere il
suo posto voleva salire sopra evitando
così andremo a testare 3 gadget per cani
se non avete visto il video presidente
in cui testiamo 4 gadget per cani andate
a vederlo perché abbiamo 60 dei grazie a
super divertenti ve lo lascio alla fine
di questo video perché potete andare a
vederlo il momento migliore per testare
dei casi più per cani e quando sono un
pò stanchi così almeno non cercano di
mangiarseli e non li grati erano lì
mordicchiano allora iniziamo subito con
il primo gas
come sempre vi lascio il link
descrizione di dove li ho comprati tutti
suono amazon.com prevede spazi il primo
grado
ecco allora questo è una bottiglia
dell'acqua per cavi e mi dirai ma ce ne
sono tante inversa di bottiglie di acqua
per cari per quando andate in giro col
vostro amico peloso e dovete appunto
portare un pò d'acqua per dargli da me
figlia però è speciale andiamo subito ad
aprirle a testarla si erano tre colori
celeste verdeaqua rosa e grigio e io ho
preso per marino ovviamente il verde
perché mi ricorda il colore di strigno
davvero allora perché fas italia
berlino professor salire sul tavolo si
sdraia sequestro
allora ci hanno regalato un laser
penso però che sia per appenderla ciao a
tutti sono ben vero che un pulsante
hanno posto dovrebbe essere il clicker
che in pratica è un metodo per
addestrare i cani e cioè invece di usare
i biscottini premi si usa il clicker
questo non penso che lo utilizzeremo
perché preferiamo addestrarlo con i
comandi vocali e dandogli i biscottini
anche mai berlino avrà un giovane sì ma
non siamo così tanti esperti quindi
consegnate sicure nei commenti se
dovremo provare ad addestrarlo con il
mio se si attenziona molto bella piazza
ti piace allora il contenitore non è
grandissimo la prima cosa che ho notato
è che in pratica si può premere un
pulsante e l'acqua andrà direttamente
qua così farò da sola per il cane ora la
pesca subito andiamo prima ad aprirla
c'è anche un laccetto per tenerla appesa
alla porta allora devo dire che berlino
è veramente un cagnolino con due
padroncini che fanno video perchè gli
piace stare di fronte la videocamera
guarda allora vado a riempire
questa questo contenitore l'acqua e
vediamo subito se funziona e si ammalino
piace allora nel frattempo berlino ad
istituti addormentarsi sulle mie gambe
berlino 6 un po di sete per caso allora
ecco qua il mio si sente evitare ha
riempito la borraccia bottiglietta
allora bisogna sbloccare qua penso così
perché ora l'acqua fortunatamente non
cade viene bloccata da questo sistema
così è meglio per quando l'ho portata in
giro
ok acqua bloccata il velino che voglio
guarire bene
premiamo il pulsante ed ecco rilassa
l'acqua vediamo se berlino la beve dove
perché tremonti berlino che aveva la
bocca tutta sporca piace si sta facendo
un po un casino diciamo che all'aperto è
più comodo perché tutto il resto
dell'acqua cadrà per terra o nell'erba
appunto però funziona e devo dire che è
comodo perché si può rilasciare un po di
acqua alla volta e appunto non cade poi
quindi questo caso mi piace tantissimo
dio merlino contro le teorie vie anti
rotolamento di gioco ma non proprio che
mi chino diciamo che è abituato a
spronare la sibello verdino allora te ne
rilascio ancora un po visto che è così
tanta sete caspita
cliccando proprio la punta nella dovesse
l'acqua
oddio disastro più notare usare questa
borsa in casa ovviamente perché sapete
che i cani quando bevono fanno un po di
capitolino ecco merlino continua a bere
bravissimo allora che voto diamo questo
gadget
ovviamente non è da stare in casa perché
avete potuto vedere il catino però
merlino è piaciuto un sacco penso che
sia molto pratico mezzo mezzo
mezzo punto in meno perché la borraccia
un po piccoli natanti ma continua anche
un cliente sarebbe pronto a dire sì
concordo e anche berlino prova perché
gli è piaciuto veramente tanto dare un
voto anche voi nei commenti da 1 a 10
questo gadget e poi alla fine del video
vi metterò il sondaggio per farvi votare
fare mi piace che mi è piaciuto
che cos'è questo gaza abbiamo una
palettina per pulire i bisognini dei
nostri amici cagnoloni o cattivi si è
quindi una specie di anche perché lo
vuole vedere quella è una specie di
paletta che include la apriamo un altro
tempo si include anche lei sa che sei
una paletta è una specie di paletta che
si può aprire in base alle dimensioni
dei bisogni del nostro rimane di sophie
se non sbaglio c'erano anche varie
misure e volta misero anche la misura
grande no per ora per berlino va bene
quello che poi dietro c'è un pratico
combattimento dove ci sono anche le
bustine quindi adesso facciamo una prova
perché sapete che bisogna sempre
raccogliere i bisognini dei nostri amici
pelosi stia che li passano per strada
altre che i fattori casa ovviamente del
lido è diventato un bravo cagnolone
clima quasi sempre fuori allora
praticamente in questa palettina
possiamo togliere il sacchetto limitiamo
a quanto è grande cosa che a tutti è un
po troppo grande eccolo qua si tolga il
sacchetto bisogna togliere il sacchetto
a pirlo e inserirlo all'interno per
muoverli galan bravi a scapito poi
bisogna aprire in base alla dimensione
abbiamo praticamente una palettina con
il sacchetto e facciamo finta che questo
è il nostro bisognino dell'inter
non vi facciamo vedere con il vero
nemmeno avrei motivo marino guarda come
praticamente questo e se questo è il
bisognino si va così con la paternità
scatta pure i sassi toglie così così non
dovete insomma toccare e fantastico
questo grazie solo a loro si chiusero
userò sempre praticamente sicuro voglio
usare anche berlino lo volontariato è
fantastico questo è davvero il preferito
per il governo il nuovo questo sì ma
come rivia utilissimo soprattutto se si
è in giro per strada sapete che a volte
è complicato raccogliere tutta la
cassetta dei nostri amici pelosi
soprattutto bisogna prendere subito la
bustina raccoglierla sicuro è tutto già
pronto praticamente si porti via solo
questo dell'attacco pure qui bene anche
perché rimane pulito perché praticamente
una volta messa la bustina non non c'è
nessuna parte da contatto con loro
prendiamo un arrivo credevo per me
infatti io pensavo che si sarebbe
sporcata ogni volta la palettina anche
all'esterno noti storica quindi questo
caso e temperamento gauthier negozi
glorioso che dirò un voto 10 perché
aiuterà tantissimo raccogliere tutti i
bisogni di berlioz
marco apertasi e voi che voto gli date
da 1 a 10
scrivetemi commenti ora possiamo al
terzo che un certo budget e questo
gadget e un gadget super divertente
in pratica questo gadget anzi prima lo
provvediamo se riuscite a indovinare
dove berlino non è proprio un caso se
diciamo in qualcosa di molto divertente
allora non so se riuscite a capire da
qua ma è una criniera da leone
in pratica se volete trasformare il
vostro cane il leone basta prendere
questa in più a una cinghia e stringerla
e così se il vostro cagnolino più
gravando più piccolo ovviamente non è da
lasciare sempre al cane è giusto per
divertirsi momento fagli qualche foto da
leone farli qualche video però se gli dà
fastidio ovviamente non va lasciata
troppo tempo e sono troppo curiosa di
vedere merlino il re leone secondo me
diventa bellissimo se se la lascia
mettere vediamo allora si inserisce
acqua e io devo stringerlo un po perché
berlino ha solo cinque mesi quindi
curiosità vuole che mi lascia mangiare
browner league fra tutti devono mangiare
ma che bellucci no
che se vanno destro persino fatti vedere
vediamo se riusciamo a sistemarlo io sto
già mangiato tutto da qui dentro sembra
davvero le ore perché ha lo stesso
colore quasi ecco un altro che
assegnando la singetta a lui pensa che
sia un pupazzetto uno dei suoi giochi ma
oggi ottavo benissimo benvenuto troppo
da ridere quando l'ho visto sotto forma
di leone proviamo a risistemati confidi
constellation può vederlo meglio perché
fantastico bravo allora l'abruzzo sono
riusciti a metterlo dandosi su frutto
preferito e cioè la bella ma così bello
o ridere è fantastico ciao rino si no
il leoncino ho visto più da vicino
[Musica]
questa mattina della mentre sbadiglia
però con la logica delle ore
[Musica]
allora che voto diamo questo terzo
gadget come divertimento 10 a sono
concluse e super divertente vedere il
proprio cagnolino trasformato e un leone
si ricordano al cane potrebbe dare
fastidio soprattutto si è agitato perché
adesso berlino si era un po agitato e
quindi quando si agita vuole giocare
confronto mangiare tutto sono cinque
mesi
ok adesso che è più calmo se lo fa
essere meglio siamo sei bellissimo
sentimenti proprio il prezzo di quindi
vi consigliamo voi comprate questo gas
volete vedere anche voi cercare
trasformati leoni media fino a quando
sono tranquilli rilassati in ogni
modalità gioco non se lo tolgono questo
giorno così come valuta questo vi do un
8 perché appunto dipende dal cane a
cameron vuole lasciare sopra o no adesso
che sta che si formerà non si lamenta
produrre leoni regolino e come sempre ci
siamo divertiti troppo e anche di fare
se volete vedere un terzo episodio in
cui testiamo altri gadget per cani e
andate a vedere quello precedente però
lo shock ubiqui lasciate un bel mi piace
è ora vi lascio 4 casoli linea su cui
piccard e che cosa su quella preferita
e voi